in the Sci-Fi comedy Galaxy Quest
there's a scene where a human pretending
to be an alien is horrified by the food
his species is supposed to like
while the scene is played for Laughs
it's interesting to think about the
strange little details of alien daily
life that most stories don't include
enter the Berg project a World building
series that brings to life in expansive
alien ecosystem but also delves into the
most minute cultural details of its
Central Intelligence species
created by the brilliant artist Ripley
the Berg project doesn't just explore
the biology of its titular aliens but
also imagines how they put on clothes
how they play the horn even how they
sneeze
so for this entry into the archive we'll
explore the Incredible World of the
Bergs and as usual you can follow the
artist on social media and see more of
her project using the links in the
description now let's explore this Alien
Planet on both a macro and micro scale
we'll start with the burgs themselves
also called bird bugs these
extraterrestrials superficially resemble
a cross between Earth birds and Earth
bugs and have developed a level of
intelligence similar to our own the
planet they evolved on is a habitable
world with extreme seasonal variations
meaning the Bergs must hibernate for
much of the year
internally Berg bones don't all connect
the way ours do as the ancestor of most
land animals on their Planet had an
exoskeleton like Earth insects in the
Elon since Bergs and their kin have
convergently developed vertebrae to
support their necks but their ribs are
still free-floating
bergmels are made of two Nimble Pinchers
that can move independently as this
biomechanical visualization illustrates
this means that verb Jaws function more
like the mouth parts of Earth spiders
than a vertebrates another visualization
of berg biomechanics shows us how the
creatures breathe they take in oxygen
through apertures near their eyes which
in turn lead to lungs located in their
neck and then they exhale from exhaust
apertures on their sides and as
mentioned before here's how a Berg
sneezes
like humans Bergs have a range of facial
expressions they use to communicate
emotion to our eyes these Expressions
might be hard to read but to Bergs these
emotive displays are just as intricate
as our own with mandibles eyes and
antennae position coming into play
you may have already noticed that most
birds possess fine hairs over much of
their bodies which helps them keep warm
during The Long Winter months of their
Homeworld
much of the Berg's rounded shape
actually comes from this fluff and
without it they appear like withered
skeletal life forms
because of their fur clothing isn't the
same kind of cultural requirement it is
in most human societies yet many birds
still wear garments to further Shield
themselves from the elements show off
their wealth or denote their nationality
for bird societies are just as complex
as our own
and like humans Burg civilization has
been shaped in no small part by the
numerous other species on their Planet
trunk horses are among the most
invaluable species to Berg Society
serving as both steeds and guardians of
verb children this mayor keeps a
watchful eye on her foals as she grazes
and while one of her foals looks
different from the others she guards it
just as fiercely another steadfast
companion of the Bergs or the zhabja
dog-like creatures that have been at the
Berg's side since the dawn of their
civilization like Earth dogs many breeds
of jabja exist with most acting as pest
control and highly territorial guardians
of Farmland like cats jab ja are largely
self-domesticated meaning they chose to
integrate with Berg's society as a
survival strategy and birds keep other
types of pets as well here a child
proudly display lays their prized scale
bugs these colorful creatures spend
their larval stage in the bark of
certain trees where they are collected
by local kids and raised to their adult
stage these vibrant pets are considered
fashionable and function almost like
living jewelry
Bergs also cultivate insects called
Pottery bees in large Farms the bees
themselves are rarely consumed but a
fungus that the bees grow for food is
considered a regional delicacy
populations are carefully maintained by
local Keepers protecting the large mud
nests with fences and moats it is custom
for pottery Bee Keepers to leave a small
token as payment for the harvested
product
on forms the larger bumblebird
classification of insects plays key
roles as pollinators many plants have
co-evolved pits full of sugary
reservoirs to lure in Bumble Birds who
then spread their pollen to other plants
a convergent relationship to that of
flowers and Earth bumblebees
most insects on the bird Planet are
covered in Scales which have developed
into protective exoskeletons in some
clades many flying clades of insects lay
their larva within specific crops and
sometimes play a vital role in the life
cycle of the plants these strange
parasites are a hugely important
resource to the burgs both as
pollinators and as food and are also
consumed for their mind-altering
properties
for birds who live on the coasts most of
their food comes not from the land but
from the sea Coastal Bergs partake in a
wide variety of seafood fresh from the
planet's Bountiful oceans fish within
the Waters of the Berg Homeworld take on
a variety of curious and startling forms
with most possessing the multi-part
mouths common throughout most lineages
on the planet some of the largest
creatures in the ocean are filter
feeders with specialized mouths that
funnel zooplankton into baline-like
structures on their jowls while these
creatures might not look at they share a
common ancestor with the dog-like jalbja
that the burgs keep as pets Elsewhere on
the coast there's also a species of
crab-like life forms which is good
because all speculative settings should
have some form of crab
further Inland the flag deer Family
Sports some of the tallest creatures
found on Berg World these towering life
forms are related to the trunk horses
although their trunks have become
lengthy flagpole-like appendages used to
reach leaves on the tops of trees much
like the long necks of Earth giraffes
on the opposite end of the spectrum
snuffling around the bottoms of trees or
pig-like armored herbivores that feed on
bark and Roots their short mandibles can
inflict serious harm on would-be
Predators so most creatures keep their
distance
the tree-like plants of the Berg Planet
are quite different from trees here on
Earth Sun spiers or towering plants with
leaves that grow in tightly clustered
Chambers like giant compound eyes these
lenses act like a magnifying glass
helping to optimize photosynthesis in
the burgs once used them to make
decorative Windows Sun Catchers and even
primitive spectacles and telescopes
today sunspire lenses are more commonly
formed to make distinctive jewelry
a ubiquitous group of trees are the
feather veins plants that are named for
their feather-like assemblage of leaves
though equivalent to Earth trees in
certain ways feather veins diverge in
their production of walking seeds a
mobile stage of their reproductive cycle
that can amble along in search of Ideal
land in which to begin the more familiar
plant stage of their life cycle
different walking seeds have different
specializations and most briefly fill an
insect-like Niche within their ecosystem
in silica-rich soils Landscapes of
coiling vines dominate the scenery these
Mounds take thousands of years to reach
their current size with successive
layers of vines growing on top of the
old ones in a reflike fashion and like
Marine reefs they support a diverse
assemblage of life including local birds
that hunt for small game
yet Bergs aren't always the ones doing
the hunting many birds are still very
much in the middle of a larger food web
and there are various apex predator
species that can turn a Berg into their
lunch especially during the planet's
long Winters when Birds need to
hibernate
and there is no deadlier predator of the
hibernation period than the ohm the
source of the Berg's darkest Legends
these beasts have sensitive
mechanoreceptors on their legs that
allows them to locate Burrows hidden
underground the Ohm's habit of exhuming
hibernating animals has inspired
countless horror stories of berg homes
being torn into in the dead of night for
even at mid-latitudes Berg World Winters
are easily as cold dark and vicious as
those seen in the far polar regions of
Earth nothing roams these snows save the
lumbering beasts that Prey Upon the
bones of the dead as readily as they
rest sleeping creatures from their
hidden Burrows
aesthetically and thematically the bird
project takes inspiration from the 1984
Hayao Miyazaki film nausicaa of the
Valley of the wind based on a manga of
the same name the film tells the story
of a post-apocalyptic Earth with a toxic
ecosystem where the last humans
struggled to co-exist with giant insects
the visual parallels between The Surreal
insect-dominated ecosystems of nausicaa
in the Berg project or evocative during
the early stages of production director
Miyazaki created several watercolor
paintings to help decide the look of his
futuristic biosphere and these early
storyboards in particular echo through
the style of the Berg planet
in different ways both stories explore
themes of conflict between society and
nature again and again in nausicaa
humans are reminded that the Earth is
something beyond their control in trying
to resist this only ends in
self-destruction likewise for all their
intelligence the Bergs don't have
dominion over their unforgiving Planet
they are just a single thread in a
larger ecological tapestry with all
aspects of their culture shaped by their
environment
yet different Burg civilizations have
different relationships with nature as
bird cultures are as rich and varied as
our own one of the most influential
groups are the two we Birds who control
a vast Empire of interconnected cities
cultures across the two-week kingdom are
endlessly complex with an emphasis on
folklore and ceremonial formalities
when a tuwi dies family members carry
the body to a special room where it
naturally mummifies and they keep it in
there for a year-long grieving period
the body is then cremated and spread to
the wind with any remaining ashes mixed
into the clay of a little sculpture made
to resemble The Departed loved one
most Tui buildings are waddle and dab
made from the gray bluish wood of
feather vein trees and bundles of
fibrous grass stuffed into the walls for
insulation
for food one of the key staple crops in
the two-wee Empire are a tuber-like
fungus that act as roots to the feather
vein trees with their Agriculture and
city building the two we are quite
different from most nomadic bird
cultures
yetuis still engage in many traditional
bird practices like The Grooming of each
other's fuzz to remove dirt and unwanted
parasites this social grooming behavior
is not unlike that of certain Earth
primates and is a way for the birds to
deepen their social bonds
some of the most esteemed community
members or Moon Watchers shamans who
forego winter hibernation in order to
guard their sleeping communities from
the physical and spiritual horrors of
the Long Cold Night For even in the Tui
Empire birds are never fully separate
from nature
of course Tui aren't the only burgs with
distinct cultures some Burg societies
practice scarification using scoring
techniques to create cosmetic patterns
in their fuzz growth in Mossberg
societies have their own form of music
like these ceremonial horns designed to
resemble the mouths of trunk horses due
to Berg's unique biology the mouthpieces
cover their exhaust Vehicles unique
instruments present in the 2B Empire are
standing devices functionally similar to
the accordion with Bellows pumped by the
medial arms while the anterior hands
press the keys
nearly all Berg societies engage in uh
chemical Recreation which can range from
grub fruits which have perception
altering effects on birds to the shaved
bark of certain plants which relaxes
their mind and body in bird culture
these stimulants play an important role
in Social bonding and are expected at
most Gatherings one of the weirder forms
of recreation the birds have involves
Slumber bugs scorpion-like creatures
that produce Venom which Medics have
historically used as painkillers however
some birds use them less responsibly
which over centuries has led to various
breeds with creative names and
variations in potency while not outlawed
Slumber bug use is widely seen as a bad
idea
like many ancient and modern human
cultures birds have created a wide array
of Mobility AIDS canes and crutches come
in a few different forms with their
shape depending on which bird glim needs
the most support
in the windy equatorial region strange
statues suggest Burg civilization has a
long history the singing Giants
Mysterious Statues that make an eerie
Whistling noise when the wind blows
through the holes in their heads lies
scattered on the planes their original
purpose is unknown but the local Nomads
believe their humming or the voices of
passing ghosts
muchaburg religion is tied to seasonal
changes in environmental forces some
communities participate in ritualistic
brush burning removing dead grasses so
new ones can spring up
at seasonal festivals Birds who wish to
show off Don flashy costumes and circle
around each other in a mock battle
referees judge participants in these
dancing rituals on their synchronicity
and how close they stay to their partner
without touching them
and like all known human cultures Burg
societies have Legends of Monsters one
of which this folk costume is meant to
depict as on Earth most of these
mythical beings do not actually exist
but perhaps some do a widespread Legend
among Bergs tells of an eerie creature
something like a great worm with many
legs that stalks the thickets at night
some say they come from the underworld
or perhaps they are mischievous spirits
of the wild but in truth these secretive
nocturnal life forms are called millipes
a highly intelligent species that
quietly coexist with the burgs in the
remote corners of the planet their exact
intelligence is difficult to measure
perhaps they are as smart as dolphins or
perhaps they are just as intelligent as
the birds themselves in any case these
wise elusive beings have stayed hidden
from the Bergs for Untold Generations by
retreating into huge dirt Mounds during
the day perhaps one day as Empires like
the two we continue to expand a fateful
meeting will finally occur
some of the most interesting pieces from
the verb project depict the experiences
of the Tui and other groups on the edge
of the frontier they show an almost
Mythic landscape of Discovery and danger
aesthetically these Works take
inspiration from a very unexpected
source for a work of speculative biology
The Cinematic language of westerns one
of the largest genres of film for over
half a century classical westerns told
stories of exaggerated heroism in a
mythical golden age of freedom in the
modern era however so-called
neo-westerns have sought to re-evaluate
the folk stories of the old west
examining the era under a more
self-aware and critical lens while
thematically the Berg project strongly
Echoes the latter aesthetically many
pieces play clever homage to old-school
pulp westerns taking the iconography of
Gunslingers horses and outlaws and
translating them into a new dialect of
alien imagery for example one image
translates the classic Trope of a cattle
herder into something decidedly unique
here we see a shepherd on a trunk horse
watching over their livestock these
animals themselves aren't valuable but
instead serve as host to a sort of tick
that is sold as a delicacy in Tui cities
on a Dusty Street Corner in a city an
old herder idles away in the afternoon
sun far from a heroic folk tale life in
these settlements is often tough in
short
in the two we Borderlands a proud
Captain Bears a flag of her modest gang
rear-end adornments are ubiquitous into
we Society but flags are more formal
used to identify important members and
war parties into distinguished friend
from foe
Tui who Venture Beyond City Limits must
come prepared headgear for shielding the
eyes and Saddles adorned with packets
for carrying personal items are key it
is also common to wear under clothes to
stay protected from the wind and dust
this particular bird doing the modeling
is named swoose and she is something of
a protagonist in this strange
neo-western Mythos
in one of the most expressive pieces
swoose races through the canyon lands
having drawn the ire of a large aerial
Predator while she still has her firearm
it's not doing her much good like most
neo-western protagonists swoose
experiences more Misfortune on the
frontier than dazzling heroics more
broadly this section of the Berg project
Echoes the neo-western motifs of
ordinary people trying to live ordinary
lives yet struggling to survive
it seems fitting that a project with an
emphasis on minute details would take
inspiration from a genre built on
stories of the ordinary yet the Berg
project is too unique to be pinned down
to any single genre the artist states
that they feel the project has expanded
Beyond its Western roots and has become
a broader exploration of how people
interact with and are shaped culturally
by their environments even if in this
case the people or six limbed aliens if
you find this project as fascinating as
I do you can support the artist on
social media and see more of the Bergs
using the links in the description
and as always thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this entry please lend your
support by liking subscribing and
hitting the notification icon to stay up
to date on all things curious see you in
the next video